[Music]
for today's video we are going to do
some mobile development
and i don't mean developing for mobile i
mean using a mobile device
to develop i am going to code and deploy
a web app while using nothing more than
a single
phone and my weapon of choice the iphone
11 pro max
s plus limited edition 256 gigabytes
there is an issue when i make videos
when i make a youtube video i have no
idea if the thumbnails are
interesting or not i wish i can a b
test them but i can't as you know
thumbnails are extremely important
because it can make
or break your video no matter how good
your video is
if it doesn't get clicked it doesn't get
watched
so i wish i can test my thumbnails to a
small audience
before i publish it so i had an idea
why not create a web app where people
can decide between two thumbnails
which would they rather click and use
that information to build a ranking
system
of your thumbnails and other people's
thumbnails so you can know how well you
rank
against others probably wouldn't work
because
people don't want to click dumb
thumbnails for no reasons
doesn't matter it's a pet project
whatever it's settled we are ranking
thumbnails and to do that
i need a ranking algorithm yep
i need an algorithm
give each thumbnail a base rating of a
thousand four hundred at any given time
thumbnail a has rating r a thumbnail b
has rating rb
when any two thumbnails are matched up
there's an expectation who will win
based on their current rating right
yep and those expectations are expressed
this way
all right let's code it
we're gonna need a stack and i think i
found the perfect candidate
no js she is a wild card
sometimes she makes no [ __ ] sense but
god damn i'd be lying to you
if i said she isn't high performant with
that single threaded event-driven
architecture
you cannot deny her abilities to handle
multiple simultaneous connections
alone she's pretty impressive already
but paired for web framework
mind-blowing and nobody else makes no
jazz shine brighter
than this one express a lightweight
node.js web application framework
together they are the definition of
synergy
and then there's mongodb the supplier
stores and distributes data like no one
else
highly available highly scalable
finally angularjs the face of the
operation
if you ever need a con man he's your guy
and together
they form the mean stack
so basically we want a web app server
node.js web app server you know we
will use express also and then for the
front end
we're going to want angular so i'm
essentially creating a simple diagram
of a typical mean stack as a skeleton
and then
filling in more things like my model
schema
so for our thumbnail we're going to be
needing the url
of the youtube url and then maybe like a
rating so that we can actually rank them
maybe our title and then also the image
url
so that we can actually access the
thumbnail so that's going to be our
model
now i continue to put details and start
expanding by adding things like the
services that i will use
and how these services will interact
with each other for example we have
heroku
a platform as a service to host our
nodejs application
so we don't need to deal with servers
mlab a database as a service
so we don't need to maintain our own
database an
aws server so i can actually use a
normal
operating system like ubuntu since ios
isn't made to code on you're not going
to be able to use your phone
as a computer but you can ssh
into that aws server and you can do that
with an app called terminus i think it
will be easier than i thought
because once you ssh into your aws
server
you're essentially controlling a
computer and you can follow any tutorial
as if you were on a desktop and just
code like you would
and voila the diagram of our
infrastructure
all right so i've set all my cameras up
finally
okay that took a lot more effort than i
thought so
let's start coding okay so the first
thing we want to do
as you know i will be coding the whole
app using only my phone
so from searching on the internet to
coding and deploying the app
everything has to be done on a phone so
my goal is to set up a workable
development
environment and be able to push to some
sort of production environment
so my plan is to do the following
generate a key pair for my phone and an
aws server
launch aws ec2 using my web browser
on my phone ssh into my ec2
using my phone push a starter node.js
app
onto heroku for production set up
nodemon to develop faster
locally and last but not least just code
the entire app
easy all right let's see how i'm doing
copy that copy
all right and then we can generate
wow this is this is not very good on
mobile to be honest
well i mean it's it's not their fault
it's not meant to be on mobile but
okay so then now we're gonna import keys
so basically i
import the key pair into aws so that i
can use it when i launch a new ec2
instance
but launching it isn't quite as easy
with the ui
on the phone i can't see anything i can
see [ __ ]
okay well um i could see that kind of i
could kind of see the symbols
i want ubuntu so oh that's one i think
that's 18.
okay i want the 16.04 ah this is it i
think
wait all right cool i can't see [ __ ]
okay these buttons don't work so for
this is our first obstacle um
let's try this
okay all right there we go
easy okay so we're just gonna launch
this
after i configured all my ports to be
open to any ip address
because i'm promiscuous like that i
launched my ec2 and took a little asmr
break
while i wait for it to boot up
oh my god i then configured a new host
for termia so i can ssh into my aws
server
on my aws server i installed node.js
installed tmux pushed a starter app to
heroku
and got nodemon to work so i can quickly
test my app
indexes okay cool let's
change oh let's change the word getting
started let's do
write drama here okay and then what we
do
now is we save the file
okay so now we save the file we refresh
this
oh excellent joma started on heroku
excellent all right
so now we have it so we can code here we
can use vim to code
and then we could like use nodemont to
keep running it and we could look at
this link
to see if it works or not okay so now
i'm going to take a break because like
that took
way too long for what's supposed to take
two minutes but because i did it on the
phone it took super long
i mean i haven't figured out all the
tricks yet so maybe i'll figure that out
while i code it
so um yeah okay
i'll work on it
[Music]
so
[Music]
the code can be separated into three
parts first the back end which i copy
pasted from this tutorial
i just replaced bare by thumb and
modified the api appropriately for my
needs
then for the web page i just needed a
simple bootstrap template
a few modifications and some light css
was sufficient
lastly our angularjs code i put my data
binds in the right places and i was able
to connect my application data
to the dome
okay so so basically my left thumb
and my kind of my right thumbs but
mostly my left and um
yeah i think it's because i've been
coding a project
on my phone right yeah it's it's for a
video so
so i had to like code the whole project
like a coding project on my phone
and then every time like i swipe to go
to like chrome and stuff like that
that's where it hurts like when i do
this right
um okay um when did it start
uh well like maybe like two weeks ago
because that's when i started
doing the coding project oh okay well
have you considered that maybe it's
related to how
you're using your phone
yeah but i mean like is there like any
way where we can like type without
paint because like i still have to do
that project no i don't think so
i think you just have to stop using your
phone so much
[Music]
i don't think i can finish this app
on my phone unfortunately my thumb hurts
and it hurts a lot every time i swipe or
like i type
there's just this really sharp pain
right it's really really sharp pain
and i don't think i can continue doing
this
like it's probably not possible
but i mean there is this one thing that
i can do but i
really really didn't want to rely on
this
[Music]
but i don't think i have any other
choice now
so
[Music]
this is great i am
loving it oh my god i am blazing fast oh
my god
this is so good oh wow
this is probably the best thing that
ever happened to me
all right i am done let me show you a
little demo now
okay let's go here
so the app is pretty simple as you can
see i'm clicking these thumbnails and
each time i click a thumbnail it means
the match has been won
by that thumbnail and if you click at
the top you get the result page and here
you can see the results of your ranking
you can see the ratings and it's ordered
by ratings you know
cool cool you can add more thumbnails
actually i'm going to delete all these
thumbnails first
[Music]
so here i pasted a youtube url and i get
their thumbnail
right here i could also add my own
thumbnail
that is not attached to a youtube video
you know give it a title
tiger king
and there you go and if you look at the
main page you'll see that these two
thumbnails are going head to head
all right and then after giving a pink a
win you'll see that the score has
increased
so that's pretty much it very simple app
with lots of potential to add more
features
but for now i'll just keep it at that
keep it simple since it's supposed
to be a toy project so i can show off my
phone dev skills and uh yeah that's
uh that's pretty much it yeah
all right well
i'm glad it's over um yeah i'm so done
with my phone
like my eyes hurt my thumbs are you know
i think i need a digital cleanse
and i think that's what i'm gonna do you
know i think
i'm starting to appreciate disconnecting
myself from
the digital world you know not be so
binded by technology and the internet
i mean especially social media right so
you know maybe this is a good thing like
maybe finally i could
you know get some reading done so i
think that's what i'm gonna do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you